so it was during these cycles of
violence in 2012 that you gave Mr dap a
knife as a gift
I gave him a knife
um I think for a birthday present early
in our relationship I believe it was
around 2012 but I'm not certain
we've seen a picture of that knife but I
think we should bring out the real thing
Master deputy
halusa Master deputy sheriff Colusa may
I please have you
show the knife to misheard
yes that's it
that's the knife you gave to the man who
was hitting you right mustard
I wasn't worried he was gonna stab me
with it when I gave it to him that's for
certain but you gave it to him while he
was abusing you allegedly I gave it to
him that year now miss heard I'm going
to need to talk to you about what
happened at Australia in March of 2015.
you've testified that at some point
during the incident you described you
witnessed Mr Depp bashing the phone
against a wall right that is correct you
testified that the phone was breaking
into pieces
I was watching it disappear now Mr def
smashed it I think your word was
smithereens
yes that is correct
and according to your testimony this was
a wall-mounted phone in the bar area
that is correct
let's take a look at defense exhibit one
eight two zero you saw this photo during
your direct examination right that is
correct and you testified that the
wall-mounted phone that you saw Mr depth
smash is on the wall on the left
that's correct so if you were looking at
this picture the wall the wall mounted
phone would have been behind you on the
left hand side of your shoulder but it's
not depicted in this photo correct
whoever took this photo standing right
in front of where that
um Mountain phone was
convenient the pieces of the phone Mr
def smashed yarn in this picture either
right
you don't see it because it's whoever
took this photo standing in front of
that
whoever took this photo it's Mr Ben King
correct that's what I believe yeah Mr
King testified under oath in this trial
right that is correct and he testified
that there was no wall mounted phone
smashed to Smithereens that he had to
replace correct I didn't hear him
testify to that no
he did the council elicited it I
disagree with that representation
you also saw this picture
actually can we please bring out
defendants exhibit one eight two one
which is also admitted
into evidence
you also saw this picture during your
direct examination correct that is
correct and so this is the bar area to
the right of the wall mounted phone you
just described
if you were facing in that direction if
you're facing this direction it would be
behind you
this phone on the counter isn't the
phone that got smashed to Smithereens is
it no they brought that out
um during my testimony in the UK as well
and I said this in the UK trial as well
but that is not the phone obviously
because that one's not smashed and it's
not wall mounted yeah so there are two
phones in the bar area
there there was a wall mounted phone I
don't know if it was decorative or what
but it was what like it looked antique
large and antique
and and what the large and antique one
that's not depicted in any photograph
including ones you took is the one that
missed for depth damaged correct that is
correct I only took pictures of the
mirrors
so there's no picture of that damaged
phone I didn't take a picture of it no
so you testified in this courtroom that
after Mr Duff smashed the phone he held
you down on the countertop by the neck
do you remember that
I'm not quite sure of the exact sequence
of things but yes both of those things
happened
okay we'll get to the sequence
this is when Mr Depp supposedly
assaulted you with a bottle right
on the countertop he assaulted me so Mr
Depp was able to get you on the counter
right he held me down by my neck and
hold you down by your neck
that is correct and he grabbed a bottle
according to you
while holding you down by the neck
correct I'm sorry can you clarify what
you're asking me
while Mr Depp is holding you by the neck
against the countertop he grabs a bottle
that's her testimony no those two things
didn't happen at the exact same time no
while he so he's holding the bottle is
that your testimony holding you down by
the neck sorry what was your question
your testimony is misheard that either
he has the bottle before or after he's
holding you by the neck on the counter
is that your testimony he held me by the
neck on the counter
where's the bottle
that he's at what point
while holding you down by your neck
when he was assaulting me with the
bottle it was in his hand
was it in his hand before or after he
holds you down by your neck
I was being held down while he assaulted
me with the bottle
when he puts you on the counter does he
have the bottle in his hand yes or no
as I have always said I don't remember
exactly what happened first or I don't
remember the sequence I just remember
being aware that I was being assaulted
by a bottle while I was on the
countertop so he penetrates you with
this bottle
but you don't know how he got the bottle
right that is correct and he did that
right after he lost the tip of his right
middle finger again I don't remember the
exact sequence of those events Mr dupp
lost the tip of his finger after you
threw a bottle at him isn't that right
that is incorrect you're the one who
assaulted someone with a bottle in
Australia isn't that right Miss heard I
didn't assault Johnny in Australia I
didn't assault Johnny ever I couldn't
and then after he was injured he had to
hide from you right that is five
bathrooms two bedrooms that is incorrect
and you would pursue him
that is incorrect because he was
avoiding talking to you right he did
that first night when he was avoiding he
talked to him about the drugs and he was
avoiding working it out
no he was uh avoiding
agreeing to not fight about the drugs
you weren't scared of him at all were
you
I have a uh
a mixed relationship with Johnny and one
in which I'm scared one in which I love
him very much I'm not talking about your
mixed relationship that night in
Australia after you cut off his finger
with a bottle you weren't scared of him
at all were you
this is a man who tried to kill me of
course it's scary he was also my husband
you were here in this courtroom right
Miss heard when Malcolm Connolly
testified to taking this picture
that's correct
this is the picture this picture shows
an injury to Mr Depp's face doesn't it I
disagree
I've seen this picture
not injured in it he's not injured in
this picture that's your testimony fine
this one is uh Photoshop it's heard
I have your answer thank you
this is the only photograph from our
honeymoon that shows someone with an
injury correct that's not true
we haven't seen any photos of injuries
to your face from that train trip have
we
I don't believe my face was injured on
that trip hence screaming when I spilled
wine accidentally on you from falling
asleep and screaming in front of my kids
and freaking Jack out
and that's trying
yeah you're right
you're right Charlie that [ __ ] him up
you know sorry
no it's it's weirded him out it never
[ __ ] my kids up but
it was pretty [ __ ] it was pretty
[ __ ] away from you know
[Music]
you're right
[Music]
I don't need your uh
you're clever uh
come back no you think you're
controlling yourself you think you're
controlling yourself
actually
making you making me see you know worse
and believe me I'm not gonna be calling
you at three o'clock in the morning
after I have an Ambien and I don't know
trust me
it is
gross
I've done nothing
but be there for them in a good way and
you can take that for them to try
you're right meet a woman who would not
jump up and scream machine but if things
go on through
Mumford and I hope I hope you're happy
with whoever that is because that would
be a special kind of person
it's you and Mr death in that recording
right that's correct then you're
discussing what happened in the Bahamas
in December of 2015 right
uh no that's not correct we were
discussing a part of it
you're discussing
when you screamed it Mr death in front
of his children correct uh no we were
talking about
a part of that argument including when
you screamed at Mr death in front of his
children that's not a fair
characterization of what happened
Mr dab says you're screamed at him when
he accidentally spilled wine on you
correct I realize that's what Johnny
said yeah and Mr debb tells you that
this freaked out his son jack
Johnny often used other people to back
him up in our arguments
concerned about that do you
I had a lot of concerns
you don't seem you don't
mentioned Mr death sexually assaulting
you in this recording do you that was
not the point of that conversation if I
had
gotten into the details of what happened
to me with him it would have been
another fight
you just accused Mr dapp of quote using
his kids right
in that record often use other people
yes
and you challenge him to find a woman
who will not quote jump up and scream if
she has been spilled on three times in a
wrote row that is correct
not a woman who would put up with sexual
abuse right
I was pointing out the ridiculous nature
of him expecting me not to react to
something that basic
[Music]
Ally
we're on the road
stop the process I don't want
it you're not going to be
there
we don't
apologize
I never want to divorce I didn't want
you to [ __ ] go to Coachella without
[ __ ] talking to me because I left you
because
[Music]
you [ __ ] hang after me man you came
around the bed a [ __ ] start punching
on me
[Music]
why
[Music]
that's what really happened the evening
of your 30th birthday isn't it misheard
no that's incorrect Mr death wasn't bad
and then you came around the bed and
started punching him that's incorrect
don't deny that in the recording do you
miss heard I'm not having that
conversation with Johnny I'm not denying
anything I'm not saying anything I'm not
having that conversation with Johnny I
was trying to get out of that hotel room
uh that was a mediation attempt that was
the recording you just heard it was us
meeting in a hotel
but you're talking about your 30th
birthday no we're not you're not talking
about going to Coachella and
Johnny's talking about that I am not
arguing with him about any of that right
you don't deny anything do you I'm not
talking to him about that